these are the top three viral moments
from the bad Friends Podcast starting
off with the first time Rudy jeweles
brought a knife to the show hold on is
that music oh are you cleaning a
knife yeah what is that for um I just
bought it wait wait whose knife is that
I've never seen that knife before in my
life Rudy's weapon Obsession has left
all of us laughing throughout the years
but not as hard as Andrew Santino
laughed while showing Bobby the now
famous I want to be Ninja
song a this Asian lady how is she
standing there through this there's four
minutes of this all right first of all
if I was that
Asian turn it off and at number one is
by far the most viral bad friends moment
yet when the boys started talking about
each other's moms I'm Bobby
mom you're so mean dude bad
friends just hit 1 million subscribers
on YouTube and in honor of achieving
this massive milestone